[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Грунівська Січ,
Слобожанщина]
Це козацьке дерево.
Метою його є така вправа:
[Володимир Вакула
Господар садиби «Грунівська Січ»]
треба таким чином залісти нагору.
Цьогоріч Січі буде п'ять років.
Сюди їдуть усі з різних причин.
У нас  багато дітей упродовж літа.
Ми називаємо їх джури, бо це учні козаків.
Дівчат більше.
Вони підготовлені психологічно,
фізично, емоційно.
Хлопців — менше.
Дитина приїздить, бо батьки привозять.
У нас є дівочий і чоловічий курінь.
Вони селяться і вже знають,
хто чим займатиметься.
По-перше, треба знати, де коні,
навчитися вивести коней, привести їх.
напоїти, осідлати,
їздити, якщо знаєш як.
Наступного дня — самоосвіта й самосвідомість.
Вони вже знають, що їм робити:
о котрій прокинутися, які їхні завдання,
де потрібно підтягуватися,
бігти крос або йти на руханку.
Найголовніше, коли до нас
приїздить кілька дітей уперше,
то це джура — у них уже ройовий.
Приїхали діти 14-15 років.
Я призначаю їм наставника 10-12 років.
Пояснюю розпорядок дня:
сніданок, обід, вечеря
ударна техніка, навички верхової їзди,
ковальство, читання лекцій,
розповідаємо, хто ми і як тут живемо.
Козацька зброя, крос, купання в річці.
Ми дозволяємо перебувати тут дорослим,
коли вони не зверхні над дітьми.
Ми не посилаємося на те, що вони —
батьки або мають більше досвіду.
Рівний рівному — відповідальнісь така ж.
Ми тільки контролюємо процес.
Я в 16 років пішов працювати на завод.
Я дуже хотів вчитися. Мої батьки прості люди.
Здобув професію токаря по дереву.
Пішов в армію, прийшов з армії.
Став підприємцем
шляхом помилок, вивчення
економіки, фінансів, правознавства.
Двадцять років на це витратив.
Займався технологіями, будую помалу.
Усі знання, які я здобув упродовж життя,
інтегрував у громадську ініціативу.
У мене була ідея (зараз місія) — зрозуміти,
чому люди не цікавляться своїм корінням.
Я зрозумів, що модель родини
й культура домашнього побуту має велику роль.
Довго шукав навпомацки.
Дорослих не зміниш, тому зайнялися дітьми.
Я почав досліджувати сучасне козацтво.
Почав їздити Сумською областю.
Я не знайшов жодного місця,
прикладу відновлення козацьких традицій,
куди можна приїхати,
доторкнутися до козацьких речей.
Ми пішли таким шляхом:
створили садибу сільського зеленого туризму.
На мою думку, це — колиска відродження української культури,
традицій і патріотичного виховання молоді.
Є 7 куренів.
Тут не було ні проведеної води, ні каналізації.
Пічки поклали, плиточку зробили.
Більшість зробили ми самі.
Тут є ідея створити бібліотеку.
Збираємо дуже цікаві книжки,
які стосуються України, історії, козацтва.
Діти мало читають сьогодні,
тому я їх заставляю.
Спочатку кажу:
«Прочитай книжку Сірка».
Класна книжечка.
Тут ми зробили отаку кухоньку.
На кухні ми готуємо усі.
Нема сенсу вчити щось далі,
якщо не можемо приготувати собі їжі й
розрахувати на братів, сестер, друзів, пригостити їх.
Це дуже важливо.
Культура домашнього побуту починається з нас,
як ми себе тут поводимо, так ведемо і там.
Ми створюємо фестивалі, семінари, форуми,
модеруємо День міста,
де презентуємо себе у різних форматах:
від сучасних до традиційних й культурних.
Один день на Козацькій Січі,
козацька лицарська школа цілий рік,
вона унікальна — одна в Україні.
Таборування, форуми, вишколи, сесії.
Через це пройшло
більше п'ятнадцяти тисяч людей.
Україна починається з тебе,
із того, що ти повинен бути не трутнем,
а робити свій внесок:
волонтерський, професійний, будь-який.
Мені кажуть, що я трошки хворий.
Кажуть: «Нащо воно тобі потрібно?
Треба заробляти гроші в житті,
а не дітьми займатися.
Усе одно нікому ти не допоможеш».
Я щасливий тому, що роблю.
Сидіти-плакати, чекати й казати:
«Держава нам нічого не дає.
Хтось нам грант якийсь дасть».
Можемо чекати ще 50-60 років і не дочекатися.
Просто треба брати й робити своїми руками.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори: Олексій Панченко,
Олег Сологуб]
[Режисерка монтажу
Юлія Рублевська]
[Субтитрувальниця
Богдана Капіца]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]